several countries across the world have
taken extreme lockdown measures to
contain the spread of the corona virus
but could that happen in a country as
big as the United States and what would
it take I'm chatting with Business
Insider senior science reporter Aria
Bendix over Skype to address some of
these burning questions so aria is it
possible that the US could go into a
total lockdown it's possible I mean
we've seen them really implement
stricter measures especially over the
last couple of days you know almost a
week ago it was limiting public events
with more than 500 people we've seen
that reduced to about 250 then now down
to 10 so they'll continue to implement
stricter measures can you see cases of
the death count rise but what would need
to happen for us to get to that point so
there's no part in fast line I'm not
sure that government officials even know
it obviously right now we're
implementing restrictions on a statewide
basis or you know a basis so be up to
individual leaders to determine when
they're either the case count or the
death count was not too high and we're
not implementing the appropriate
measures to start to contain the spread
but as we continue to see cases rise
we're just gonna have to get stricter
and stricter with what we do to try and
contain this virus and some cities are
doing just that but what do cities need
to do if they want to implement
something similar to a lockdown so it's
not that hard to do we've already seen
San Francisco implement a
shelter-in-place measure and that means
that unless someone has essential need
to be outdoors or to get to their job
that they can actually be fined or face
imprisonment for going outside but with
a current unnecessary reason that
obviously doesn't include you know
walking your pets or getting to work but
and they're actually you know
emphasizing that they are going to be
compassionate about these rules we
obviously understand these are difficult
times but it's pretty dire straits at
this point so what does that mean for us
will we be fined if we go outside yeah I
mean we have seen past precedent for it
in San Francisco you can already receive
a
if you are going out for a nonessential
reason in Italy we've seen that you had
to carry around actually a piece of
paper explaining your reason for being
outdoors South Korea has also
implemented fines I think ultimately
especially in the u.s. they're trying to
exercise compassion with those types of
rules that they do implement them I
understand that this is difficult time
that people do want to have some fresh
air but ultimately this is a necessary
measure to sort of protect the public
safety at large now this is a question
that I feel like many in my circle want
to know the answer to but do sometimes
have some countries implemented these
rules but with exceptions for people
with dogs or pets yeah there are
exceptions for people with dogs or pets
we actually know that pets can't
contract the virus but we understand
that they need to be outdoors to sort of
do their business so that's one of the
reasons why you know pet owners would
have a legitimate excuse for being
outdoors they should still make sure to
practice the safe distancing of six feet
from another person and it should only
be just a reason to walk your dog and
get back inside if your city has already
implemented one of those self isolating
policies Sariah as a country when did we
start taking this seriously
so I just spoke to a laboratory
researcher in Seattle who actually
developed his labs on Kovach 19 tests so
he was telling me that the u.s. actually
started taking this pandemic now
seriously about two to three days ago
and that was when we started
implementing some of those stricter
social isolation measures it was
actually also when we realized that we
were sort of in the same boat as China
and Italy in terms of our death count of
the way that cases have risen probably
should have been a bit more proactive
with our social distancing measures
because we do know that that's one of
the most effective ways of containing
this virus and the fact that we've
waited until now means that we might
have to resort to more drastic measures
in the future
[Music]
[Music]